[Música]
Hola hoy en sciencelich pulsares y
estrellas de neutrones
desde la tierra el cielo nocturno brilla
con multitud de motas brillantes en su
mayoría se trata de estrellas enormes
masas de plasma en fusión que irradian
una intensa luz debido a su elevada
temperatura
Aunque parpadean ligeramente El brillo
de las estrellas es bastante estable y
no varían intensidad
pero en los años 60 observando el cielo
en otras longitudes de onda los
astrónomos descubrieron puntos
brillantes que parpadean a lo largo del
tiempo estos puntos parecen emitir
oscilaciones extremadamente regulares su
luminosidad pulsa de forma metronómica
los llamamos pulsares
para comprender de dónde vienen estos
púlsares Tendremos que sumergirnos en la
vida de una estrella nos interesaremos
en una estrella 10 veces más masiva que
nuestro sol
la estrella quema su combustible en un
proceso de fusión nuclear el núcleo de
la Estrella libera energía hacia el
exterior lo que le permite contrarrestar
la presión de la gravedad y mantenerse
estable
Pero al final de su existencia después
de 100 millones de años nuestra estrella
se agota se ha quedado sin combustible y
la fusión nuclear de su núcleo se
detiene la estrella ya no está más en
equilibrio nada se opone a la atracción
de la gravedad y el núcleo comienza a
colapsar Bajo su peso
a medida que se contrae el núcleo de la
Estrella se comprime su temperatura
aumenta a varios miles de millones de
grados y comienza a girar cada vez más
rápido generando un campo magnético cada
vez más potente
el núcleo se vuelve tan denso que las
partículas que componen la materia se
ven obligadas a fusionarse los
electrones entran en los núcleos de los
átomos y se unen a los protones
forman neutrones y el proceso emiten un
enorme cantidad de neutrinos
[Música]
de repente el núcleo es tan pequeño que
los neutrones colisionan entre sí
llegados a este punto el núcleo ya no
puede contraerse la contracción se
detiene bruscamente y las capas externas
de la Estrella son arrasadas por la onda
de choque y el viento de los neutrinos
La estrella explosiona es una supernova
la explosión de la supernova Deja atrás
de sí un gigantesco remanente una nube
de gas y polvo Interestelar que un día
puede dar origen a nuevas estrellas
pero tras su muerte el núcleo de la
Estrella no ha desaparecido pero ahora
es una pequeña bola de materia formada
por neutrones apilados se trata de un
cadáver estelar llamado estrella de
neutrones
cuando se forman las estrellas de
neutrones pueden presentarse en
diferentes configuraciones
muchas estrellas orbitan en parejas
alrededor de otra estrella
tras la muerte de una de ellas la
estrella de neutrones puede a veces
continuar girando alrededor de su
compañera
del mismo modo si la estrella estaba
inicialmente rodeada de planetas estos
Pueden seguir orbitando alrededor del
cadáver
[Música]
una estrella de neutrones es un objeto
increíblemente denso que contiene en sí
mismo la masa de varios soles en algunas
decenas de kilómetros
equivale a la masa de Plutón comprimida
en una casa
[Música]
si se comprimiera un poco más la
gravedad se apoderaría de ella y se
convertiría en un agujero negro
la estrella de neutrones también es
extremadamente caliente la temperatura
de su superficie puede superar los
varios millones de grados Celsius
debido a su pequeño tamaño gira
extremadamente rápido mientras se
encogía el núcleo Que formó la estrella
de neutrones se aceleró hasta alcanzar
velocidades cercanas a la de la luz
puede girar casi mil veces sobre sí
misma en un solo segundo un automóvil
con las ruedas girando a esta velocidad
se movería a 7.000 kilómetros por hora
en la superficie de una estrella de
neutrones la gravedad es insoportable y
da lugar extraños fenómenos de la
relatividad el tiempo está muy dilatado
si los astronautas aterrizasen en la
estrella de neutrones solo envejecerían
10 meses por cada año que pasase en la
tierra
por desgracia para ellos las fuerzas de
marea también son inaguantables la
diferencia de fuerzas entre su cabeza y
sus pies es 100 millones de veces mayor
que la gravedad terrestre se
espaguetizarían al instante
por último la estrella neutrones desvía
Los rayos de luz a su alrededor
modificando la geometría del
espacio-tiempo crea un efecto de lente
gravitatoria
distorsionando la imagen de los objetos
circundantes e incluso permitiéndonos
observar su parte trasera
la estructura interna de una estrella de
neutrones es a un poco conocida es
imposible observar su composición desde
la tierra tenemos que recurrir a modelos
matemáticos y a la física cuántica para
describir Cómo se comprime la materia
[Música]
en la superficie lo más probable es que
una estrella de neutrones esté rodeada
de una fina atmósfera bajo la cual se
encuentra una superficie perfectamente
Lisa ya que era fuerte gravedad aplana
cualquier rugosidad que pudiera
sobresalir
Bajo su superficie la estrella neutrones
tiene una costra principalmente sólida
formada por núcleos atómicos y
electrones libres
al sumergirnos más profundamente la
presión aumenta y los núcleos comienzan
a combinarse con los electrones para
formar neutrones la alta presión ayuda a
estabilizar estos núcleos pesados que
normalmente se desintegrarían muy
rápidamente cada vez más en profundidad
los núcleos se combinan entre sí y se
fusionan para formar cúmulos aún más
grandes
Cuanto más nos adentramos en la corteza
mayor es la concurrencia entre la
gravedad electromagnetismo y la
interacción nuclear fuerte lo que obliga
a estos cúmulos de materia a fusionarse
más abajo los núcleos forman estructuras
alargadas en formas de tubos a mayor
profundidad estos tubos son forzados
unos contra otros y se fusionan formando
una pila de capas apiladas unas sobre
otras finalmente estas capas se fusionan
y los espacios se cierran gradualmente
dejando solo algunas burbujas en un
líquido de neutrones
estas diferentes estructuras que forman
redes geométricas en el interior de la
costra constituirían uno de los
materiales más resistentes del universo
que los investigadores denominan pasta
nuclear
en efecto su geometría recuerda a la de
los ñoquis los espaguetis o la lasaña
nombres que los científicos utilizan
para clasificarlos de forma intuitiva
si decidimos sumergirnos aún más nos
aventuramos Más allá de los límites de
la corteza y entramos en el núcleo de la
Estrella de neutrones
aquí es donde la presión es máxima el
núcleo de una estrella de neutrones
alcanza los límites actuales de nuestros
modelos la presión es tan intensa que
entra en juego los principios de la
física cuántica
en particular las partículas están tan
cercanas que se repelen Por el simple
hecho de que no deben superponerse esto
se denomina principio de exclusión la
forma de materia cuya estructura se rige
por el principio de exclusión se
denomina materia degenerada
la materia degenerada sigue siendo un
misterio y existen varias hipótesis
sobre su estructura podría tratarse
simplemente de neutrones apilados pero
los neutrones no son partículas
elementales sino que están formados por
quarks y se podría imaginar que bajo
tales presiones los quarks se separarían
para formar un súper fluido o incluso un
plasma de quarks y gluones cuyas
propiedades serían exóticas
el interior de una estrella de neutrones
sigue siendo un Enigma que los
investigadores intentan resolver
activamente
durante su formación la estrella de
neutrones adquirió un campo magnético
extremadamente potente los científicos
son capaces de generar campos magnéticos
de varias decenas de tesla suficientes
para hacerle evitar objetos e incluso
seres vivos pero una estrella de
neutrones genera un campo magnético
varios millones de veces más fuerte este
campo magnético es tan intenso que
incluso puede alterar el vacío
proporciona el espacio extrañas
propiedades de refracción cuántica la
luz que pasa puede ser desviada dividida
o recombinada
al igual que un imán el campo magnético
de una estrella de neutrones sale a
través de un Polo Norte envuelve a la
estrella y entra en ella por un Polo Sur
Por tanto la estrella de neutrones tiene
un eje magnético que en la mayoría de
los casos no está alineado con su eje de
rotación
cuando gira el campo magnético de la
Estrella de neutrones sigue esta
rotación creando intensas fluctuaciones
que se propagan a la velocidad de la luz
razonablemente cerca el campo magnético
de la Estrella neutrones atrapa la
materia circundante y la obliga a
permanecer cerca de la Estrella por el
contrario a gran distancia el campo
magnético varía tan rápidamente que abre
y acelera las partículas cargadas hacia
el exterior de este modo la estrella
neutrones produce dos Ases de ondas
electromagnéticas extremadamente
potentes que escapan a lo largo de su
eje magnético como un faro cósmico estos
haces de radiación atraviesan el espacio
periódicamente y emiten una señal cuyas
oscilaciones pulsan metronómicamente
cuando la tierra está en medio
observamos un pequeño punto brillante
que parpadea en el cielo es un pulsar
[Música]
desde los años 60 Las observaciones de
púlzares se enumeran y se clasifican
según su frecuencia de oscilación
Cuanto más rápido Gira la estrella de
neutrones sobre sí misma Más rápidos son
los pulsos que observamos en la tierra
podemos clasificar diferentes
poblaciones de púlsares algunos giran
muy rápido a casi 1000 rotaciones por
segundo la mayoría de estos pulsares se
encuentran en sistemas binarios
orbitando alrededor de una estrella
pueden acelerar a estas velocidades
extremas capturando materia de su
compañera
por el contrario otros pulsares giran
más lentamente a razón de unas pocas
revoluciones por minuto
la rotación de una estrella neutrones es
extremadamente estable su precisión es
comparable a la de nuestros mejores
relojes atómicos pero durante los miles
de años de su existencia pierden
lentamente energía por radiación y por
la curvatura del espacio-tiempo
poco a poco los pulsares pierden
velocidad y acaban realizando solo unas
pocas rotaciones por minuto
Durante este proceso de ralentización la
superficie de la Estrella se ajusta a la
fuerza centrífuga y adopta una forma más
esférica de repente la superficie
desciende unos pocos micrómetros en
menos de una millonésima de segundo
estos fenómenos tienen el efecto de
acelerar ligeramente la rotación de la
Estrella
normalmente las poblaciones de púlsares
se clasifican en un diagrama que muestra
su velocidad de rotación frente a la
velocidad a la que se ralentizan
encontramos pulsares binarios que giran
muy rápido y son muy estables Y pulsar
es más lentos que se ralentizan con el
tiempo
desde la tierra observamos todo tipo de
radiación la mayoría de los púlsares
emiten ondas radio pero otros pueden
emitir rayos x más energéticos debido a
su rotación y a su fuerte campo
magnético o incluso rayos Gamma
algunos de estos pulsares tienen Campos
magnéticos tan fuertes que los llamamos
magnetares emiten poderosos rayos x y
rayos Gamma de forma irregular lo que
los hace muy difíciles de describir
[Música]
hoy conocemos cerca de 3000 pulsares en
nuestra galaxia
desgraciadamente la gran mayoría de las
Estrellas de neutrones siguen siendo
inobservables desde la tierra esto pues
tienen ases muy finos que no abarcan
Nuestro cielo y nuestros telescopios
actuales solo detectan los púlsares más
activos
estos objetos siguen siendo misteriosos
y poco conocidos
pero los púlsares tienen un interés sin
precedentes en el mundo de la astronomía
pueden permitirnos probar la teoría de
la relatividad general llevándola a sus
límites más extremos o comprender
comportamiento de la materia bajo
presiones tan intensas
nos proporcionan relojes cósmicos de
extraordinaria estabilidad
en junio de 2023 su estudio confirmó la
detección de un fondo aleatorio de ondas
gravitacionales de baja frecuencia con
una longitud de onda cercana al tamaño
de una galaxia
indirectamente los pulsares podrían
aportarnos información sobre la
naturaleza de la materia oscura y la
existencia de agujeros negros
primordiales son también muy buenos
puntos de referencia para que los
satélites orienten y finalmente es
alrededor de un pulsar donde se
observaron los primeros exoplanetas
[Música]